hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome no I died oh I'm going why I
like it I like don't even have it Oh God
[ __ ] I'm not ready for uh you you ha
stop dammit
pad just getting my hand oh welcome back
to fruit ninja now well [ __ ] really
ok alright then
so brew ninjas game that I played it's
actually one of the last games that I
played while I had the vibe back in my
old place and it's something that I left
behind because it was so unbelievably
frustrating but now that I got the
wireless set up I think it's gonna be
way better because I'm gonna be way good
or at it
cuz that's words that use good so here
we go now I don't want to play classic
mode classic mode is for dumb babies who
like things old which is why people
watch me bland okay so let's that weary
weary hello ah got him well didn't mean
to do that
I got you I got you what oh yeah oh yeah
oh yes yo yo here we go this is the [ __ ]
that's what I like
yes okay well the music stopped now and
I feel a lot of lot less excited about
what was happening I didn't mean to do
that did not oh shoot shoot eat couch I
got two seconds
well that two seconds amounted
absolutely dick diddly but not oh that's
terrible
oh that was an awful score I did awfully
ah okay something tells me I didn't
capitalize on my combo but that's not
why I'm here
the mode that I actually like is
survival because survival offers
challenge and rewards skill of which I
have numerous amounts of hang on one
second - shut up
there we go little quieter okay alright
and as everyone knows I have gratuitous
amounts of skill stop laughing so the
trick of this one yeah you can't get 3x
you can't miss three times but you get
bonuses depending on how you don't miss
whoa hey calm down there titty sprinkles
it's the first round ooh I'm gonna get
you you think you're gonna give me the
answers you're not and I hate you ooh Oh
get him get him Oh what up hey yah oh
yah uh-huh hey yo hey yeah yeah well
yeah ah [ __ ] ah brick miss one that's
okay because yeah uh oh well that's not
good Oh
ha got him because every hundred you get
a free me whoa Oh also that happens got
a freebie yeah yeah Oh shitty dicks Oh
got him you can't be me what who the
Frick frack a titty Winkle or I'm gonna
get you this is a game that gets me
frustrated cuz I just like I keep going
for it no matter what I'm like always
always pushing myself to new limits cuz
I'm so good at what I do and I'm amazing
I'm a ninja don't you believe me I hunt
enjoying I am whoa
what you got nothing oh yeah pop feel
like not today not tomorrow not on
Sunday it [ __ ] am i [ __ ] I mean fruit
cuz I'd really hate to think all this
fruit was going to waste you know whoa
hey
whoa blow blow [ __ ] oh this is a lot
of waste to be perfectly honest what how
on whose authority
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay is aa freebie you do a
little dance cut a little fruit get down
tonight huh no okay ah stop being a
douche not today I think I got all of
that anytime I actually think I'm doing
good I'm actually missing completely
Kiwi all right come on I've got a whole
lot more if you got a whole lot more on
your end let's see who's got more on
this unlimited fur planet hi yeah yeah
we could solve all the world's hunger
but you guys choose to throw it at me
and I just have to defend myself oh yeah
oh yeah yes oh I'm glad no no I went
blind no you deserve to die no I was
blind
goddamnit I was doing totally fine huh
alright come on let's see what you got
no Paul I got him chunk just throw them
onto my sword [ __ ] never mind
alright I'm gonna try hard this one so
no jokes no jokes everybody shut up oh
oh oh come on faster faster come on I
wish it was like an extreme setting not
that I could handle that probably died
right I went to anyway but just good for
my own ego come on you think you can do
this you think you do where'd it go damn
it
he's gonna do that to me the answer is
yes obviously but I don't like it we're
hence the complaining who what no what
the hell damn yo no God really really ah
give me that freebie I need it oh I mean
I don't need it but I quite obviously
need it there we go okay can't miss one
ah
no Joel Joel okay well I'm building back
no God dingus damn me to [ __ ] hell why
does it keep why do I keep going I'm
blind I can't see a thing why why does
it keep going blind like that it must be
like the wireless thing it's a little
janky it's not quite a hundred percent
perfect I mean don't get me wrong it's
really cool well what the hell it's
really cool but also it's not perfect
this is the one game on vibe that I so
give me sweaty so Rhys it's more from
the anger than from the actual like
athleticism of it I'm doing worse than
ever
I'm never gonna beat that high score
ever in my life whoa whoa whoa whoa
sonny jim whoa whoa whoa eat a tick yeah
what the hell my tracking went off ah
this Wireless thing it's messing up my
score it's really cool and fun it off
for my scar
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa easy
easy there Sonny Jim come on come on
come on come on come on come on you
think you can you think you can well I'm
here to tell you that you cannot what no
yes yep yep Rurouni no Peroni beyond the
window lung City a Guam no wow that
markiplier he's so handsome and skilled
and great at cutting fruit is a real
provider is a provider of entertainment
and sustenance what a man
what oh come on what a man no no no no
no no not that I'm just getting to the
good part where are you going where are
you on friend where are you going
no no no no come on whoa how what dude
I'm on alive how am i alive I don't
understand that entirely but I'm okay
with it
well I all right that is that I love
this game
but I hate this game do you understand
the complex emotion that have to go
through a man's body to be able to
comprehend something of that nature I
think not so anyway that is fruit ninja
I like it a lot maybe I'll save this for
a stream someday because it's a casually
fun kind of game so thank you everybody
so much for watching let me know what
you thought down the comments below and
as always I'll see you in the next video
[Music]